in this video I'll reveal my techniques
for enhancing flat vector graphics
specifically for HUD and UI design by
adding depth and dimension for a more
engaging experience
[Music]
hi my name is Cameron and I'm the
creator of motion science before we get
started today I want to invite you to
join my complimentary workshop at
motionscience.tv Workshop where I unveil
my personal techniques and hidden gems
that I use in my daily workflows this is
a free workshop and takes about 30
minutes don't miss out on your chance to
level up your skills and make sure to
visit
motionscience.tv Workshop after watching
this video you won't regret it now to
kick start this project I need high
quality vector graphics since I lack
artistic skills I prefer to use
pre-existing Graphics rather than
creating them from scratch I have a
membership to embato elements as well as
free pick which are great resources for
finding simple and visually interesting
HUD UI shapes and Graphics while there
are plenty of free options available on
websites like free pick and others some
of them require crediting the Creator
however I opt for or paid membership
sites like envato elements to save time
and have access to a wide variety of
assets quickly this way I can focus on
finding the perfect elements for my
projects rather than wasting time
searching for free assets once I have
selected the vector graphics that I
believe will work well I import them
into illustrator and I organize them
into layers this allows me to manipulate
and adjust each element individually I
then bring the layers into after effects
and convert them into 3D layers this
allows me to add depth and dimension to
the graphics to ensure that the layers
remain sharp and clear even at larger
scales I enable the option to
continually rasterize layers this
maintains the quality of the graphics
even when they are scaled in After
Effects I utilized the Z plane in 3D
space to arrange and spread out the
layers this allows me to create a sense
of depth and dimension within the
composition it also enables me to create
a more Dynamic and Visually engaging
design by adding movement and animation
to the graphics in 3D Space by using
these techniques I can take flat vector
graphics and turn them into interesting
and dynamic visuals with depth after
arranging and spreading out the layers
in 3D space I add a 3D camera to the
composition this allows me to explore
different angles and perspectives to
find the most visually engaging
Viewpoint once I have identified an
angle that I think will work well I
create a keyframe and begin
experimenting with simple movements if
you're familiar with my work you know
that I prefer to use OneNote cameras
rather than a two node camera this
allows me to use fewer keyframes when
animating my camera once I have
established the camera motion I enable
depth of field for the camera this
technique creates a more realistic and
natural visual by blurring the
background and foreground elements I
also increase the aperture of the camera
this increases the amount of depth of
field and helps in creating a more
immersive and engaging visual experience
for the viewer overall these techniques
and tools enable me to take a static
design and add a sense of movement and
depth to make it more visually
interesting and engaging once I have
established the camera motion and depth
of field I like to add an additional
layer of visual interest by
incorporating fractal noise I create
another 3D solid layer and I apply
fractal noise to it I then adjust the
brightness contrast and overall size of
the fractals to achieve the desired
effect to add movement to the fractals I
animate the evolution by creating a
couple of keyframes and adjusting the
parameters over time
to integrate the fractals into the scene
I set the animated fractal layer to be a
Luma matte for the vector layer beneath
it this allows the fractals to reveal
the graphics below creating a sense of
depth and movement by using this
technique the fractals add an additional
layer of visual interest and movement to
the scene making it more engaging for
the viewer I make any necessary final
adjustments to the camera motion and
focus settings to ensure that the
composition is visually balanced and the
movement is smooth I pay attention to
the details such as the movement of the
camera the focal length and the depth of
field to make sure that the final
product is polished and Visually
pleasing to the viewer this step is
crucial in creating a cohesive and
engaging visual experience to enhance
the visual appeal of the composition I
add an adjustment layer to the top of
the stack and apply two effects the
first effect is deep glow which creates
a subtle organic halo around the edges
of the graphics adding depth and
dimension the second effect is noise is
Alpha which adds a subtle texture to the
piece creating a more organic and
natural feel to add contrast to the
scene I duplicate the background solid
and I drag it to the top of the layer
stack I then set the blending mode to
Overlay this darkens the scene and adds
more contrast making the graphics pop
and stand out this helps in creating a
more Dynamic and visually interesting
composition by adding contrast to the
piece finally I add a solid layer near
the bottom of the layer stack to this
solid layer I apply the grid effect I
adjust the settings of the grid to
achieve a size that complements the
other elements in the composition by
adding a grid I create a sense of
structure and organization in the design
and also help to establish a clear
visual hierarchy additionally to create
a sense of depth and movement in the
scene I duplicate some of the assets and
I offset them slightly this creates the
illusion of more elements and activity
in the scene making it more Dynamic and
engaging for the viewer this technique
also helps to add interest to the design
by creating a sense of movement and
depth and there you have it my
techniques for enhancing flat vector
graphics specifically for HUD and UI
design by adding depth and dimension I
hope this was both informative and
entertaining for you if you enjoyed the
video please hit that like button and
consider subscribing to my YouTube
channel for more content just like this
your support means the world to me and
it helps me to continue creating content
I would love to hear your thoughts on
the video so please leave a comment or
question below as always thank you for
watching and I look forward to
connecting with you in my next video
foreign
[Music]